All right. What you got?
>> So I look at this and believe it or not
I, I came to an answer by two completely different ways.
>> Okay. And do they, do they agree?
>> They, they happen to agree, but one of them
is kind of lame. It's sort of the thing that you
would do if you were doing the SAT or the GRE
and you wanted to quickly get a guess at the answer.
>> Oh, I see.
>> And it's that k, very small k and very big k are kind of both easy.
It's the one in the middle where it gets hard. And
so any function that depends on k directly, in a way
where as k gets bigger it gets harder, as k gets
smaller, it gets easier, is probably not right. Which made me think
was probably n cubed. And so then I tried to think
about how the algorithm worked. And so, the worst case way
of thinking about the algorithm is at every single time you
have to figure out which two points are closest to one another.
>> Alright, hang on a sec. So we're going
to repeat k times, and the hard case is when it's, like, n over twoish, right?
>> Right.
>> And what, what is it that we do at each step?
>> Well, we find the two closest points.
>> Good.
>> Right, and that, and how long, and yeah, and how
long does that take, it's exactly, it's n squared. because you have
to do all possible combinations. It's a little better than n
squared, right, it's, you know, but it's big O of n squared.
>> Right, and it's possible
that if we store those distances really cleverly we can get it down a
bit more, but, yeah, n squared seems like a nice way to characterize it. So
don't we need to do some work to merge the clusters together so that
the next time through we get the
right set of distances that we're looking through.
>> We could do that and that would work fine and
that's probably the right thing to do, but just kind of
at a high level, what you just really want to do
is, you just want to find the closest two points that have
two different labels.
>> Okay.
>> So what I associate with every, with every
object x is the label that it currently has.
>> So you're going to look at each pair. Ignore it if the, the labels
are the same, on both of the clusters that the two objects are in.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And otherwise find the minimum.
>> Right. And what, and I can.
>> That sort of works.
>> And I could do that in time linear in the number of pairs.
So it's still n squared, I don't have to sort or anything like that.
>> True, though we could,
it could be a little bit smarter to not
reconsider the same pairs over and over and over again.
>> That's right, you could. If you could
use, you could probably use something fancy like
Fibonacci heaps, or hash tables or something. And
in fact, I know that there are people
who've gotten entire PhDs on clever ways of
doing this without having to consider all points.
By dividing points up into little boxes where
things tend to be closer to one another.
Actually looks a lot, very hierarchical as well.
>> Fair enough.
>> Okay, so we do, we do, we do a, that
takes n squared time. How many times do we do a?
>> Well, we do it about n times.
>> Alright. So that gets us the n cubed.
And is it, is it clear that the other
ones are definitely wrong? Well, since we can do
this in n squared time, and the number of
clusters can be large, the first one is a
bad answer. The second one is a bad answer.
How about the last one? Is it, is it
possible that we could actually do this in linear time?
no. Well, for, for, for very small or very big k, maybe. Like, so k equals
2, yes, that's easy, that's linear, k equals
n, that's easy. because we started out that way.
>> I see, but for in between k's.
>> because you still have to find
the closest distance, and there's, you have to
find distances and the only way to do that is to consider all the distances.
>> Yeah, at the very least the, the number of
inputs that you need to even sniff at is quadratic.
>> Right.
>> Because the d can
be any kind of structure. So, yeah, okay.
So this is really the only answer that,
that is even close. But I think it could come down a little bit from n cubed.
>> Oh. I'm sure it could. I mean, because I just came
up with the silliest, the, the simplest algorithm that you could think
of that wasn't absolutely stupid. So I think that would. You could
certainly do better than n cubed. But not much better than n cubed.
>> All right. End of quiz.
>> Yay.